[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen viel Fußball gibt es
gleich von Norbert Lehmann ein schönen
guten Abend
ab Sonntagabend hat erstmal so gut wie
kein Zug mehr
Stillstand auf der Schiene die
Gewerkschaft EVG kündigt einen
50-stunden-streik an die Bahn spricht
von Irrsinn
viel Kritik nach flüchtlingsgipfel der
Bund gibt eine Milliarde Euro zusätzlich
doch die Kommunen sind enttäuscht
und Explosion bei Rettungseinsatz in
Ratingen werden zehn Feuerwehrleute und
zwei Polizisten teils lebensgefährlich
verletzt der Tatverdächtige ist in
Gewahrsam
[Musik]
stellen Sie sich schon mal drauf ein ab
Sonntagabend fällt erstmal kein Pferd
Zug und kaum ein Regionalzug zwei Tage
lang streckt die Eisenbahn und
Verkehrsgewerkschaft EVG sie will im
Tarif Konflikt den Druck auf die
Deutsche Bahn erhöhen die hält den
Warnstreik für restlos überzogen die
Einzelheiten von Hans-Jürgen
zweimal hatten sie schon deutschlandweit
Züge zum Stillstand gezwungen jetzt
folgt der dritte und längste Warnstreik
der Eisenbahn und Verkehrsgewerkschaft
EVG ganz verstehen dass es machen für
diejenigen die die mir abgefahren
benutzen ist natürlich immer schlecht
sehr viele Leute sind auf die Bahn
angewiesen um halt zur Arbeit zu kommen
ohne Zwang wird sich da irgendwie auch
nichts von alleine lösen und deswegen
muss man streiten um mehr Geld zu
kriegen von 22 Uhr am Sonntagabend an
soll der gesamte Zugverkehr diesmal zwei
Tage lang bis Dienstag 24 Uhr
flächendeckend ruhen um die Arbeitgeber
zu verbesserten Angeboten zu bewegen die
Wut ist groß der Beschäftigten deshalb
gehen wir davon aus dass eben die
Beteiligung auch an diesem dritten
warenstreik wieder sehr groß sein wird
das heißt es wird massive Auswirkungen
geben dabei hatte die BB erst am
Dienstag die EVG Forderung erfüllt den
Mindestlohn in die Gehaltstabellen
einzutragen bleibt aber weiter bei ihrem
Angebot
8% mehr für höhere Gehaltsgruppen 10 für
alle anderen dazu eine Einmalzahlung bei
27 Monaten Laufzeit die Gewerkschaft
fordert aber zwölf Prozent ab sofort
mindestens 650 Euro bei nur 12 Monaten
Laufzeit sie will nicht wirklich
verhandeln sondern von einem Streik zum
anderen gehen und lehnt bisherige
Angebot als nicht verhandlungsfähig ab
und das bei 10% und der vollen
inflationsausgleichsprämie ist das
völlig unverhältnismäßig ist völlig
sinnlos betroffen vom Streik sind nicht
nur Züge der Deutschen Bahn und die
S-Bahnen sondern weil auch Stellwerke
bestreicht werden genauso die
Privatbahnen
Stillstand also im fern und
Regionalverkehr worauf Bahnreisende
achten müssen und welche Regelungen
jetzt für bereits gekaufte Tickets
gelten Antworten auf die wichtigsten
Fragen gibt es in der ZDF heute App
einen Tag nach dem flüchtlingsgipfel von
Bund und Ländern nähert sich die Kritik
an dem was beschlossen wurde
einziges konkretes Ergebnis des Gipfels
eine Milliarde Euro soll es kurzfristig
zusätzlich vom Bund geben um die
geflüchteten zu versorgen und
unterzubringen erstmal nur für dieses
Jahr kein Beschluss aber in der Planung
von Bund und Ländern die Asylpolitik zu
verschärfen mit Rücknahmeabkommen
lageabhängigen Grenzkontrollen und
Asylverfahren an den EU-Außengrenzen
unklar waren all das kommt klar ist dass
es nach dem Gipfel Streit gibt wie Klaus
Burg berichtet das Ergebnis nach sechs
Stunden Ringen mehr Geld vom Bund mehr
Zeit für noch zu lösende Probleme und
dann Kanzler der das als Erfolg feiert
soll den Tag nicht vor dem Abend loben
und da ist jetzt der Abend also können
wir ihn loben also das ist so ungefähr
die Situation aber wenn man mich hätte
fragen sollen heute Morgen wie es
ausgeht hätte ich gesagt so und insofern
bin ich natürlich besonders zufrieden
schon verhaltene über die von Ihnen
geforderte zukünftige finanzielle
Unterstützung der Kommunen soll erst im
November entschieden werden wir haben
einen Fahrplan mit einem Zwischenbericht
im Juni und eine Entscheidung im
November verabredet
mehr war eben nicht drin das muss man
heute so klar sagen im Bundestag am
Morgen Kritik von der Opposition gestern
war großer Showdown im Kanzleramt
und Ergebnis
Verlierer sind erneut die Kommunen und
ihre Einwohnerinnen und Einwohner ich
bin
[Applaus]
entsetzt Zahlen reagieren wollen eine
Arbeitsgruppe soll im Herbst zu
Ergebnissen kommen selbst aus der Ampel
wird Unmut laut über das Verfahren
wenn sich von Gipfel zu Gipfel handelt
der kriegt keinen Boden unter die Füße
und deshalb ist es notwendig dass diese
Arbeitsgruppe der vereinbart worden ist
so schnell wie möglich nicht nur für 23
Lösungen hat sondern auch darüber hinaus
die Innenministerin verteidigt die
Verständigung Maßnahmenpaket insgesamt
ist sehr ausgewogen aus meiner Sicht
weil es zum einen eine finanzielle
Entlastung für die Kommunen jetzt noch
mal zusätzlich bringt es ist auf der
anderen Seite aber auch wie gesagt
Begrenzung von irregulärer Migration mit
drin der Streit wird weitergehen so oder
so
beim Gipfel nicht dabei waren die
Kommunen dabei sind vor allem sie dafür
zuständig die geflüchteten
unterzubringen und zu versorgen der
Hauptgeschäftsführer des Städte und
gemeindebundeslandsberg kritisierte dass
es keine längerfristige Regelung von
Finanzierungsfragen gab das stoße bei
den Kommunen auf große Enttäuschung aber
nicht nur das Geld ist Thema für die
Kommunen Victoria Kunzmann berichtet
Fingerabdrücke nehmen Fotos machen das
Maßband anlegen so sieht sie aus die
Ankunft in der Landes Erstaufnahmestelle
in Ellwangen die meisten die von hier
aus eine Bleibe suchen kommen aus Syrien
Palästina und der Türkei unsere
Einrichtung ist sehr hoch belegt das
heißt das ist auch landesweit die
Situation aktuell dass wir weniger
Menschen in die Stadt und Landkreise
verlegen als zu uns kommen weil die
Absicht des Landes natürlich auch ist
die Kommunen nicht noch mehr zu belasten
auch in der Gemeinde Wiernsheim bei
Stuttgart wird ein ausgedienter
Kindergarten zur Flüchtlingsunterkunft
umgebaut statt mehr Geld fordert
bürgermeister Matthias ens ein
konsequenteres abschieben im Endeffekt
ist alles Menschen ja die müssen wir
irgendwo schauen das was wir aufnehmen
müssen allerdings heißt das auch dass
man überprüft welche Menschen haben ein
Bleiberecht und welche haben kein
Bleiberecht der Flüchtlingsrat verweist
auf das Grundrecht auf Asyl in
Deutschland nur beiläufig ginge es zum
Schluss des Bundes um humanitäre
Verpflichtungen ansonsten liest man 15
Seiten lang schlimmste
abschottungsmaßnahmen die das Ziel haben
das geflüchtete Menschen überhaupt nicht
erst nach Europa gelangen sollen
diejenigen die hier sind sollen
schneller in den Arbeitsmarkt integriert
werden das wünscht sich Berthold weiß
Leiter der Erstaufnahmestelle als
Beispiel nennt der geflüchtete aus
Afrika es sind alles eigentlich gut
ausgebildete Leute sie sprechen
europäische Sprachen das heißt die
Voraussetzungen für eine Integration
wären hier sicherlich gegeben für
Bürgermeister Enz ist das zusätzliche
Geld ein Tropfen auf den heißen Stein er
fordert konkretere Maßnahmen statt ein
bisschen mehr Geld und viel vertrösten
Arbeitsmigration ist das eine
Flüchtlingspolitik das andere
energy beim Bund ländergipfel wurden ja
verschärfte Maßnahmen beschlossen damit
weniger Flüchtlinge ankommen aber heute
gibt es ja schon Widerspruch ja und von
ganz unterschiedlichen Seiten da gibt es
natürlich auf der einen Seite diejenigen
denen diese Maßnahmen noch nicht weit
genug gehen und auf der anderen Seite
diejenigen die finden es geht alles zu
weit und vielleicht zu schnell der
Paritätische Wohlfahrtsverband spricht
von einer inhumanen Abschottungspolitik
die evangelische Kirche in Deutschland
kritisiert den Fokus auf den
abschiebezahlen und dann sind noch die
da noch diejenigen die sagen vieles von
dem was da besprochen wurde geht ja gar
nicht alleine in Deutschland ist gar
nicht alleine in Deutschland zu regeln
sondern geht nur im eu-verbund und auch
aus den Ampel rein gibt es schon Skepsis
vor allem von grüner Seite da hieß es
heute aus der grünen Fraktion viel
einige der Beschlüsse müssen ja durch
den Bundestag und da werde man noch
einmal ganz genau hinschauen also die
Beschlüsse von gestern sind alles andere
als ein Selbstläufer da steht jetzt noch
eine große Debatte über eine neue Gang
Art in der Migrationspolitik bevor
Einschätzung von der Energy danke schön
und weltweit sind immer mehr Menschen
auf der Flucht auch im eigenen Land so
steht es in einem Bericht der
internationalen Beobachtungsstelle für
Vertriebene demnach ist die Zahl der
Binnenflüchtlinge im vergangenen Jahr
auf mehr als 71 Millionen gewachsen das
ist ein Anstieg um 20% gegenüber dem
Vorjahr zu den Gründen zählen
Naturkatastrophen Hunger Krieg und
Gewalt
keine guten Nachrichten für Bund Länder
und Kommunen sie müssen in den kommenden
Jahren mit deutlich weniger
Steuereinnahmen auskommen laut aktueller
Steuerschätzung fließen 2024
30,8 Milliarden Euro weniger an die
Kassen als noch im Herbst berechnet
insgesamt erwarten die Schätze Einnahmen
von rund 962 Milliarden Euro das
bedeutet auch für Finanzminister Lindner
gibt es im ohnehin schon festgefahrenen
Haushaltsstreit noch weniger zu
verteilen Frank Buchwald
deutsche Zahlen aus Tokio g7-gipfel in
Japan deshalb präsentiert Finanzminister
Lindner die Steuerschätzung erstmals im
Ausland seine Botschaft aber bleibt
Deutschland muss sparen
das schätzeergebnisse eröffnet gegenüber
den bisherigen Planungen keinerlei neuen
finanziellen Handlungsspielräume es
bleibt deshalb das Gebot der Stunde die
Konsolidierung des Bundeshaushaltes
voranzutreiben und sehr streckt sich auf
Prioritäten zu verständigen Bund Länder
und Gemeinden werden in diesem Jahr
voraussichtlich
920,6 Milliarden Euro einnehmen 16,8
Milliarden weniger als im November
errechnet damals waren die Schätzer von
Einnahmen in Höhe von
937,3 Milliarden ausgegangen weniger
Geld für den Staat auch weil die
Regierung viele Bürger entlastet hat
unausgewogen kritisiert die Opposition
ich habe den Eindruck dass ich Herr
Lindner weiterhin als Vermögensverwalter
einer Minderheit versteht und damit
betrügt er natürlich die große Mehrheit
wir haben keinen Wachstum mehr bei den
Steuereinnahmen sondern sogar jetzt
zurückgehender Einnahmen gleichzeitig
haben wir aber steigende Preise und
steigende Zinsen das heißt die Menschen
in diesem Land werden ärmer in den
Jahren bis 2027 steigt das Defizit auf
mehr als 30 Milliarden Euro jährlich
kostspieligen Projekten der
Koalitionspartner setzt Lindner enge
Grenzen ein Mehr an Ausgabe wünschen
können wir gegenwärtig mit den gegebenen
Einnahmen nicht realisieren der
koalitionsinterne Streit um den Haushalt
geht also weiter Ende offen
seit Monaten fordert die Ukraine weitere
Waffen für eine mögliche Gegend
Offensive nun liefert Großbritannien als
erstes Land Marschflugkörper mit
größerer Reichweite sie werden von
Flugzeugen abgeschossen und sollen
schwer zu entdecken sein die
marschflow-körper Treffen Ziele mehr als
250 km Entfernung
im Nahen Osten gehen die Kämpfe zwischen
militanten Palästinensern und Israels
Armee weiter das Militär tötete nach
eigenen Angaben mit gezielten Angriffen
zwei weitere Kommandeure die Islamischen
Jihad
insgesamt starben seit Dienstag
mindestens 25 Menschen bei neuen
palästinensischen Raketenangriffen kam
im Süden Israels ein Mann ums Leben
international wächst die Sorge auch
bundesaußenministerin baerbock forderte
in Berlin eine sofortige Waffenruhe
ein Großeinsatz der Polizei in Ratingen
bei Düsseldorf heute Vormittag ab über
Stunden Rätsel auf ein Explosion in
einem Hochhaus 12 Einsatzkräfte von
Polizei und Feuerwehr teils schwerst
verletzt ein 57-jähriger Mann konnte
schließlich überwältigt werden in der
Wohnung wurde eine Leiche
hatte Details
Schüsse auf die Wohnung im zehnten Stock
in der sich der Mann befindet vier
Stunden dauert der Einsatz mit
Spezialkräften und Scharfschützen es am
Nachmittag der Wohnungsinhaber in
Ratingen hinter planen abtransportiert
wird
wir können hiermit bestätigen dass ein
ca 60 sogar Wohnungsinhaber verletzt von
den Spezialeinsatzkräften jetzt
festgenommen worden ist er wird jetzt
erst medizinisch betreut inwieweit die
Verletzungen durch die Explosion oder
durch die Festnahme Erfolg sind können
wir derzeit nicht sagen die Explosion
offenbar eine Sprengfalle in der Wohnung
des Mannes am Morgen werden die
Einsatzkräfte wegen eines überquellenden
Briefkastens zu einer vermeintlich
hilflosen Person in dem Wohnblock
gerufen und dort an der Wohnungstür
überrascht diese wurde aufgerissen von
den mutmaßlichen Täter und es gab sofort
eine Explosion unmittelbar dadurch
wurden insgesamt sieben Feuerwehrleute
zum Teil lebensgefährlich verletzt und
zwei Polizeibeamter in der Wohnung wurde
zudem eine Leiche gefunden die Frau soll
aber schon länger verstorben sein es
handelt sich möglicherweise um die
Mutter des Festgenommenen der laut NRW
Innenminister Corona läuft dann nahe
stehen soll
wir müssen Moment nur dass er das ist
das kriminelle vorakte hatte aber keine
dramatische und die anderen Sachen sind
alle noch sehr ungewiss die Verletzten
wurden teils in Spezialkliniken geflogen
und die Ermittlungen dauern weiter an
und eine Gewalttat hat am Morgen auch
Sindelfingen bei stuttgarterschüttert
das sind zwei Menschen durch Schüsse
Mercedes-Werk getötet worden die Polizei
nahm einen 53-jährigen Tatverdächtigen
fest er und die beiden 44 Jahre alten
Opfer seinen Mitarbeiter eines externen
Unternehmens teilte Mercedes mit der
mutmaßliche Schütze sitzt mittlerweile
in Untersuchungshaft die Hintergründe
der Tat sind noch unklar
besorgniserregende Zahlen kommen von der
Techniker Krankenkasse Pflegekräfte
waren im vergangenen Jahr häufiger krank
als je zuvor und sie waren mit fast 30
Fehltagen im Jahr auch deutlich häufiger
krankheits andere Beschäftigte die
häufigsten Diagnosen atemwegs und
psychische Erkrankungen besonders stark
sei diese Berufsgruppe durch den
Personalmangel und die corona-pandemie
belastet heißt es
immer mehr Menschen sterben weil sie
illegale Drogen konsumieren das sei
schockierend und alarmierend so der
Drogenbeauftragte der Bundesregierung
blienert der heute den aktuellen Bericht
vorstellte bereits seit Jahren steigt
die Zahl der Toten im vergangenen Jahr
lag sie bei
1990 9% mehr als noch 2021 die in dem
Zusammenhang am meisten konsumierten
Drogen waren Heroin und Morphium
die großen Blockbuster im Kino die kennt
fast jeder die top-computer und
Videospiele dagegen sind einem großen
Teil der Bevölkerung oft völlig
unbekannt dabei übersteigt der weltweite
Umsatz dieser Industrie den der
Filmbranche schon seit Jahren aber die
die in Deutschland solche Spiele
entwickeln kommen da nicht so richtig
mit der deutsche Computerspielpreis soll
ein Schub bringen heute Abend wird der
vergeben Roman leskova
Eintauchen in die düstere Welt eines
totalitären Staates diesmal nicht als
Held der gegen das Böse kämpft sondern
als Spitzel der gezwungen wird mittels
Überwachung und anschwärzen das Regime
zu stützen eine ungewöhnliche Geschichte
präsentiert Biol 3 nominiert für den
Computerspiel Preis ein textbasiertes
Adventure mit politischem Anspruch
entwickelt vom Berliner in die Studio
Paint Backend hier freut man sich dass
auch die Politik zunehmend die Bedeutung
der Branche erkenne für uns als kleines
Unternehmen ist die direkte Förderung
wichtig und wir brauchen die auch wir
würden uns eigentlich darüber hinaus
noch eine Kulturförderung wünschen die
staatliche Unterstützung wurde zuletzt
ausgeweitet die 800.000 € Preisgeld für
den Computerspielpreis übernimmt jetzt
komplett erbund seit drei Jahren gibt es
zudem ein mit 50 Millionen Euro jährlich
ausgestattetes Förderprogramm aktuell um
weitere 20 Millionen aufgestockt laut
Branchenverband die Förderung ein Erfolg
neue Firmen sein entstanden das Budget
aber schon jetzt für dieses und nächstes
Jahr ausgegeben um den positiven Trend
zu festigen müsse finanziell
nachgebessert werden das ist eine
Situation da muss die Bundesregierung
jetzt handeln und sofort uns wieder
wettbewerbsfähig machen sonst drohen wir
da sofort wieder zurück zu fallen nach
dieser eigentlich tollen Aufholjagd die
wir gerade angefangen haben heute Abend
steht aber erstmal die Preisverleihung
im Vordergrund Deutschland gilt als
größter Videospielmarkt Europas der
Ansporn der Branche bleibt das künftig
noch mehr Umsätze bei den hiesigen
Entwicklern landen
und heute abend schaut Fußball
Deutschland auf Leverkusen Norbert ja
der letzte deutsche Verein in den
europäischen Wettbewerben Bayer tritt im
Halbfinal Hinspiel der Europa League bei
der as Roman ein harter Brocken die
Devise der Werkself heißt wir wollen in
ein europa-pokalfinale erstmals wieder
nach 21 Jahren
so fordert von seiner 11 am Abend die
beste Leistung der Dämpfer im derbe
gegen Köln kam vielleicht genau richtig
nach 14 Spielen ohne Niederlage reist
bei Bayern die Serie dennoch in der
Ewigen Stadt gegen die AS Rom und alle
unsere einzigen Trainer José Mourinho er
wartet der unerfahrene Einspieler auf
Augenhöhe
aber natürlich von Josef von formo ich
habe viele gelernt
wie ein Lieder zu sein Star Trainer der
im vergangenen Jahr mit Roman die
conference Lee gewonnen hat geizt
keinesfalls mit Komplimenten bezeichnet
alonso's Leverkusener als das beste
konterteam Europas beide freuen sich nun
auf ein Wiedersehen und natürlich wollen
auch beide gewinnen
und zur Champions League gestern Abend
zweites Halbfinale Hinspiel ein
italienisches Derby AC Mailand gegen
Inter Mailand die Gäste im gemeinsamen
Stadion gewann mit 2:0
es geht alles ganz schnell zuerst trifft
er die Jacko für Inter in der 8 Minute
so ähnlich wie früher bei rolfsburg in
der Bundesliga 3 Minuten später hat der
Ex Dortmund frei waren zum 20 schon ist
der Endstand da das Arnd bloß noch
keiner hinter vergibt Chancen AC Mailand
trifft mit Sandro Tornado den Pfosten
also bleibt es wie schon nach elf
Minuten
intersiegt als Gast im eigenen Stadion
und hat beim Rückspiel in 5 Tagen beste
Chancen Herr im Haus zu bleiben
zum Ocean Race der hat das deutsche Boot
malizia auf der vierten Etappe der Welt
umsegnung knapp den Sieg verpasst auf
dem Turn von Brasilien nach Newport USA
hatten die vier Yacht mit schweren
Unwettern zu kämpfen das us-boot als
erstes im Ziel die malizia stolze zweite
das feierte die Kuh üppig und
ausführlich übrigens ohne Skipper Boris
Hermann
denn der hat sich ja eine Familienpause
gegönnt ist aber der nächsten Etappe
wieder dabei ja sehr schön genau aber
danke
sondern im Norden Regen im Süden so
lässt sich das Wetter zusammenfassen
mehr dazu gleich von Aston terli das
heute journal moderiert von Marietta
Slomka können Sie um 21.45 sehen tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter in der Nacht
regnet es zwischen Rheinland und
Bayerischer Wald ganz im Osten bleibt es
trocken und die Temperaturen gehen
zurück auf vier Grad am Alpenrand und 12
Grad Richtung Hamburg morgen gibt es
viel Sonnenschein im Norden vor allem
ansonsten Schauer und Gewitter die
Temperaturen erreichen höchste Werte mit
24 Grad im Osten und 13 Grad am
Alpenrand die nächsten Tage bleiben
wechselhaft mit Schauern und Gewittern
am Samstag im Norden Sonnenschein sonst
so durchwachsen bei 14 bis 23 Grad und
am Sonntag geht es auch im Norden
durchwachsen weiter und damit ein
schöner Abend